[Music] Hello,
I'm interviewing you
today for a website called
Sview. We'd like to get
your perspective on some
digital issues. What can you
tell us about the CSA (French Broadcasting Authority) and its new powers?
First of all, it doesn't have these new
powers yet. It's still struggling
to
obtain them, but it doesn't have them yet. On the
other hand,
the CSA has been trying to gain powers over the
internet for 18 years, and so far, it hasn't succeeded.
The government is in favor,
but all governments for the last 18
years have been in favor, so it's
less than it seems. It's still
worrying because it's
a source of problems, and that's why we've been
opposing it for 18 years. To understand the core issue, you have to
look at it
very simply: the CSA has a
certain power, a certain legitimacy
to regulate content.
Terrestrial broadcasting is limited due to technical reasons; there are very few possible channels. There can't be
30 million
television channels in France, not on terrestrial networks,
not on
older networks, and that's why the CSA
regulates it, and that's why the CSA has a
certain amount of power.
[Applause]
Uh, as is often explained,
frequencies are allocated
free of charge to television channels,
except for... well, no, but
the CSA... it's more like
amateur radio that regulates... no,
but actually, amateur radio operators aren't
regulated by the CSA.
Amateur radio operators handle
frequency allocations by the ARC, which only deals with
the technical aspects and never touches the
content. The CSA does all the
content regulation because there are
n't many frequencies available, and they
are allocated free of charge to the channels.
And the CSA, in order not to disappear,
would like to regulate
content on the internet. That's the crux of
the matter: internet content regulation.  There
's no good reason to do it,
it's as simple as that. The
CSA (French Broadcasting Authority) regulates content on
TV because there aren't enough
frequencies. We can't
regulate content on the internet, so
for the same reasons, because there are
enough frequencies, we can open any
number of
television channels or websites on the internet.
And that's the key to
understanding the issue. After that,
understanding all the stupid things the CSA can
do on the internet is
limitless.
Labeling is a start, it's
easy, it has no major
immediate impact, but it's still a problem.
What moral code will the CSA use to label things?
They'll decide what
children shouldn't be shown, so if
morality changes,
what do we do?
That's a complicated question.
When they're in power, we'll have a
fascist state, period. We have to deal
with it. For me, it's precisely because we
give too much power to places
where it shouldn't exist that...
The fact that the mode of government is changing
shouldn't be a question of what the
next Nazi in power will do with the tools
we've created for him; the question should be
how the tools we create prepare us for
totalitarianism. We can very well have a
totalitarian state
without necessarily having the fascists
in power. The totalitarian state is already being prepared;
it's already
underway. We have elements in the
current mode of operation
that are close to totalitarianism. The
example of the powers we want to give to the
CSA (French Broadcasting Authority) is a very good example.
Freedom of expression is a
cardinal freedom; it's one of the key elements
of a democratic state structure. We ca
n't have a democratic system
if there's no freedom of expression. It's
freedom that allows us to denounce
all abuses, and therefore allows us to
protect all other
freedoms. From the moment we give
the power to an
administrative body to regulate freedom
of expression, we begin a step towards
leaving a democratic model
and the rule of
law. We find exactly the same things,
for example, in debates.  Regarding
freedom
of expression and net neutrality,
freedom of expression is one
aspect of it. From the moment we allow
operators to do whatever they want
on the network, we actually allow them to
modify society, to
modify the way people
interact with each other, and therefore to
leave their mark on the
society that comes with it. That's exactly what
Apple does with
the App Store for
iOS. It's a way of distorting
society. That's... that's captive. No,
making people captive is a method, not
the
problem. The problem is that
when you have control of
available content, an organization imposes
a moral code and a worldview, and
any divergent worldview becomes
impossible. But don't you think
that the modus operandi reflects the
underlying reasoning? No, I think it's
the opposite. I think it's
because we implement this type of...  The tool
we have is a society that is
slowly tipping towards a kind of
soft totalitarianism.
I really don't think it's because our
leaders have totalitarian aims and are
implementing tools of a
totalitarian regime. I think it's
because we're injecting totalitarian tools into the regime
that the regime is
behaving more and more totalitarianly. Could you, could you... I'm using the informal "tu" with you, could you
elaborate a little on the concept of
pay-per-view internet and, from there, let's talk about
net neutrality? What do the operators want to do? The
consequences, in a few words, the
consequences of all this... well, what the
operators want to do is quite
simple, it's a short-sighted view:
they want to recoup a little more
money than they
already do. In fact, it stems from a very basic observation:
an operator is
someone who does
infrastructure work, who builds
networks, who invests hundreds of
millions to lay fiber optics
or...  Cable or whatever, and CETA and whatever,
and in exchange for that, earns
€30 a month from
a dating site subscription. It's
a website that does almost nothing,
provides three pages, a database,
and a few search tools, and
sells its subscriptions for €30 a month. You
think that's legitimate? That's what you
need to know. The problem isn't whether it's
legitimate or not; it's that one of the
two is very jealous. One of the two worked his fingers to
the bone to earn
€30, while the other did almost nothing and,
for €30, sells you your photos
because the only content worth selling,
for example, the profiles
that people have put on it, is the only thing
Mr. Facebook has to sell is what
you gave him. He didn't
create anything. I'll open a parenthesis here.
Tell me a little bit about
your perspective
on Big Data. That's something else; I'll
keep that one up my sleeve.  Okay,
so for later, the net neutrality thing is that
the operators are trying to
recoup a share of the money
made by the people who develop
internet services. He's talking about the idea: I
paid for all the infrastructure, he
paid nothing at all, and he makes as much
money as me, and it's not fair. But
I don't know if it's fair or not, what
I do know is that it's
dangerous. The question is, how do
they want to handle this? They
want to make sure that... well,
if you describe their
ideal world, you have a subscription with
Pinin Telecom, and so you have
great access to Pinpin VOD, but
when you want to access Netflix or
YouTube, it's slow, it lags, it doesn't work
well. So, all the movies
you buy are from Pinpin VOD, all
the porn sites you watch are
from Pinpin Porn, and so on and so forth.
And so, everything you
consume, you buy books from
Pinin Bookstore.  Definitely not with Amazon.
So their
business model is to operate in
a closed bubble and to create
this closed bubble by prioritizing access
on the
network. What we're arguing is that by doing
this, you distort the
network and you distort
people's perception of the world. You no longer have
access to
information in a neutral way.
When you're on the internet
normally, you visit
any website, you never ask yourself
who hosts it, you never ask yourself
how it's connected to the network, you have
access to the entire internet, not just the
end the operator wanted to show you.
Fifteen years ago, they tried to do this
with captive portals. They did it
with portals where you arrived at the
Orange portal where you had the news, the
weather, and so on, and the goal was that you would never leave. What do
you
think this will create for
community-based internet service providers?
Actually, we're the
least at risk because,
well, our subscribers have access to everything, they have
access to it however they want. If it's
expensive in terms of bandwidth, they pay a high
subscription fee, so we don't ask ourselves
complicated questions. We're not really
the question itself; we're more
the answer, the
right answer to the question.
But the crux of the problem is that you
distort, you distort people's perceptions.
You create a distorted society, in
fact, you recreate a mechanism that's just as
perverse and just as bad.
Television recreated TF1, except it's
not called TF1, it's called Orange.
When you
look at the television aspect, it becomes
difficult. So, let's elaborate a little on
your point of view on Big Data.
The questions surrounding Big
Data—well, there are a whole host of
extremely
interesting questions, but they're not on my
topic, which is business questions
and how we can do business
with Big
Data. There are plenty of people who
develop these much better than I do, and that's
the subject that fascinates me.  No, I
'm not an entrepreneur. My ambition in
life isn't to be a billionaire,
everything's fine.
Uh,
the issue for me is understanding when
it affects you as a
human being and what role
the user plays in all of this. Is
the human being in the
middle of all this just the
commodity, keeping quiet, or is there
something more
central? Do they remain, above all, a thinking,
active citizen, an autonomous and adult actor in their own life?
And this is
actually a real question that you can already
ask on simpler sites.
I can put it in a
childlike way: who owns what
you put on Facebook? You, of course.
All the other answers
are dangerous. All the other
answers say that you're no longer an adult,
that you're not free to reread your
old conversations, that you're not
free to remove the content you
posted in the past, that you're not free to
leave. And for me, there's a
central element in questions about
personal data and Big
Data, which is how you  Take back your
marbles, this tourist spot, you have to
own up to it in interviews, it's curious, sometimes
it's pleasant for the rest of the day.
The question is, in fact,
for me it almost comes down to the
question of data portability to any
Big Data system. I have no
problem with it as long as I, a
human being, an actor in my own life, can decide
to take my marbles and leave. It
could be deleting the data, it could
just be saying I'm taking them. We're talking about
a tourist spot, do you
think that the people who have just
passed through, the population, the young people, are
aware of these societal issues? It's coming, it's coming, it's coming, it's coming, it's coming faster than we think,
and
it's coming through the kids, it's coming through the
kids, they understand very
quickly. Listen, I don't get that impression. I'll
give you a very, very simple example: the
result of the Snowden affair is that
people understood what it was, that there's something
on the phone, they
understand that it exists, and when you
talk to them, they listen. When you
talked to them about it 3 years ago, they didn't listen when
you told them, uh  Your phone
constantly sends geolocation information over the network. They
quickly realize that, yes, okay,
the operators record that. Oh, actually,
they didn't know that the operator
had this information. And some operators
have close ties with
intelligence services. Yes, but it's
always the intelligence services that have close ties
with
big corporations. Okay.
[Music]
The government is buddies with the
bosses of the CAC 40. It's not exactly
new, it's not very innovative.
It was true, B. If you want, RTF. Oh, that's even worse.
Say we're on TV.
So,
if you want, for me, the closest thing to this,
I'll give you a few very simple examples:
you should be able to
download a file on Facebook in a few clicks that
contains your entire Facebook page, everything
you've said, what people have said to you, what
you've done, your entire history, your
address book, your contacts, your
friends, what you've said to
them, basically everything Facebook has on your
account. But that  It's not possible, is it? With
the current URE (Regulation of Emergency Operations), you can't retrieve it. He's the
only guy who managed to get it
back; he went through years of legal
battles to achieve it, and he was only
allowed to have it all in PDF format. It's
unusable. You should be
able to retrieve all of that in a
usable format. Okay, I'll give you another
example: your phone company has
geolocation data on your
mobile phone, and on the customer website
that shows you where they put your bills, they
put your detailed bills, who you
called, how long you talked to
your grandma yesterday—all of that. They put it all there. You can
even download the
voicemail messages. Why isn't
the data they have on you there too? Well, here it is, that's the
geolocation data we have. There's no secret. You
knew very well where you were,
but knowing that
they have the data would make you a
much more aware actor of who
you are, what you do, and what they know
about you.  He can
give that to the police about you, or he can
give it to someone else, or
maybe there's a friend who works
for Reev Norte. What system there can
access the information? Okay,
so that lets you know what
exists, and from the moment you
know who's accredited—maybe not, I assure you—
in practice, the guy who's
on the computer does what he wants,
accrediting or not, it's up to you. You have two
people for infinite power in
a company: you have the shareholder and you have
the administrator. From there, they do what they
want. Let's go back to young people for a bit. Do
young people, more and more,
understand
that they leave traces? Do they understand
roughly what kind of trace they leave? And it would be enough
if you
gave them access to the data they've
generated and made that data
portable so they can take it and
use it elsewhere, then they'll
understand very well what world they're in.
They'll understand very well what...
What they do, I think we'll even see the
emergence of perverse art forms
that consist of behaving in such a way as to
leave a pretty trace. It's like,
no, but it's super funny.
Then, as an idea, you walk around
with the goal that the
trace left by your
phone will make a pretty drawing, a
historical route through Paris, or... I don't know,
drawing... Lots of things
appear from that. Okay, I'd
like to ask you another little
question about
young people. Do you think that the
younger generation, who are a bit
younger than us, have received
sufficiently
relevant education on digital issues
since school? Are they
properly made aware of
these issues in your opinion? No, and the
issue isn't digital. What is it
then? The issue isn't
digital. It's not digital that we
need to make them aware of, it's the
network society, the society that
builds... I often say, teach
kids programming, yeah, just as much as we
teach them electronics, if you
want, it's practical.  It's good to
have a little general knowledge, to
understand the basics, to get a general idea of ​​what it's like, to
not believe in magic, to
understand that it exists, but that's not
important. The great contribution of the internet is that it
allows people to write, to express themselves, to create. Yeah, create,
you immediately take the
artistic approach, but no, just
write what you do with it, what
you write on your Facebook,
your blog, your
Twitter, or on the page you host on
your computer at home. What you
write will be read by potentially
anyone on the internet. That didn't exist
before. When my mother wrote, she
wrote a letter to someone; it was
precise. It's complicated. She never wrote in
the press. I'm describing a
much more horizontal society to you. I'm
describing a society in
which people express themselves in public,
and they aren't trained for that. For me,
the central teaching around
digital technology, all that, is really the
part of
explaining, teaching children to
Speaking in public is learning... well,
for me, the questions surrounding
the internet aren't for
math teachers or science teachers, they're
for French teachers, they're
for
philosophy teachers. Kids need to learn not to
read and write like they did in the
19th century, but to read and write to be
read, to write in public, to write to
publish. That's it. It's a
very specific kind of digital education. Do
you think teachers
actually find that with this comes a
horizontal society? But in a
horizontal society, kids do
very well on their own; they don't need to be
trained. Okay? Do you
think the national education system... do
you have a message for
the national education system? Have you ever
tried to get a
message across to the national education system in this
direction? No, I don't work much on
educational issues because they're
complicated, because they require
knowledge.  Actually, you have to know the
ins and outs, you have to know who to talk to.
I don't know that world at all. The
guy who does it really well is Michel Guillou, if you
want to ask questions about
education and digital technology. He's the guy
you have to meet. Yeah, he's
the guy who knows the subject,
who knows what he's doing, and you'll see,
he's really funny. I highly
recommend him. So, let's move on to the
recommendations. If you had one
immortal piece of advice to leave on the web for
younger generations, maybe even
two pieces of
advice: keep the internet and keep it
open. Really, both are
key elements. How do we
find them? It's easy, it's like
always: you identify who has
power and wants to increase and
keep it, and you have to hit them, and
hit them—that's a strong word. Yeah, you can.
Hitting him with a law is fine if that's enough, but
when that's not enough you have to come out
bigger. But it's exactly
like protecting freedom of expression. It's preventing
all the
newspapers from being in the hands of powerful elites. It's
preventing all the parties from being
in the hands of three lobbies. It's preventing that. It's done to keep
the game
open, and the internet is a tool
that allows the game to remain open and therefore
protects the internet for what it is. Not
networks, not digital technology. Digital technology is
useless. Digital technology is
[ __ ]. I was filming myself
digitally. If you had filmed me on film, it would have been the
same. If instead of
filming me, you had written down what I said to
copy it onto paper, it would have been the same. It had
the same value,
maybe not the same speed. Yeah, that's not even
certain. When your mother
wrote to her friend, it would have taken a
week on horseback. No, well, yeah, it
might have taken a week on horseback. On the
other hand, it was more
condensed.  More structured, therefore
more thoughtful, with less white space. It's
not the same. You pull out any
17th-century book on
politics, and it's much
denser than the crap they churn out
today. And it's not because they
're more intelligent, it's just that they
think more before writing. Do
you have any websites to recommend for getting information? Do
you have any methods? Do
you have anything like that
for getting informed? It's quite
complicated to understand
political struggles. You have some information on La
Quadrature du Net that's well
done for trying to understand the
world to come. There isn't much available
today. There are a few sites
that disseminate information, but there
really isn't much. I don't have any
systematic methods like that. So, how do you get
informed? Random, random, random. I have a
few sites I use
when I'm really bored and have nothing else
to do, like PC Impact.
Numerama or the world, that's it, but actually,
it turns out that 99% of the information
I need comes from
people. I've chosen, you've
built your network precisely, who I follow
on Twitter, and I don't follow people
who say funny things, I follow
people who say
interesting things. So I only have to
follow about a hundred people, which is
n't many. And when there's
information that interests me, it's because within the
range of topics I try to
cover, I generally get the information on
Twitter very quickly. So I get my information
much more from social networks than from a
central point. Internet governance, ah,
Internet governance, that's a
funny topic, it's good because it doesn't mean
anything. That's
one of the
problems. You talk about governance when
you have a structured organization. The internet is
n't a structured organization. It's a bit like
wanting to govern a
puddle. You can at best
try to understand,
in fact,
Internet governance...  It often presents
rather complicated and opaque ideas; it's
inaccessible to the
layperson. Basically, you have a few
American organizations responsible for managing two
or three critical resources on the
internet: distributing domain names,
managing
IP address allocations,
managing... well, a couple of things like that.
Currently, the only state with
a foothold in this is the
American government, through the
Department of Commerce, which has a foothold
in the operation of these organizations.
And we're made a huge fuss about the fact that
others besides the
United States should have a foothold in this. All of this
is essentially nonsense; it's
not interesting. It keeps
diplomats busy because it
gives them a really
interesting topic to discuss in English at
international conferences,
summits, and so on. It doesn't present any
major interest in terms of governance. If we
want to try to curb
American omnipresence, there are essentially two
problems surrounding these issues, and it boils down
to these two problems: one
is the management of domain names,
and where...  It's purely a legal issue.
The applicable law regarding
domain names is American law.
If you want to contest a
domain name, it's always the
American courts that will ultimately
decide because the large
companies that manage the
root domain names—.com, .net, etc.—
are
American companies. And that's the problem: only the
American perspective on the
law prevails.
The correct answer to this is already known and
documented. I recommend you
look at what Louis Pousin is doing on the
subject, for example. It suggests having
multiple roots in the Internet's DNS system.
This will force these roots to
cooperate with each other, making the
system much more resilient and
much less centralized. The second
problem, which is
much more
geostrategic, is
network addressing. I don't know if you know, but the Internet
as we know it is
essentially addressed by IPv4, with
4 billion addresses, and there's no
problem with the number. There's also IPv6,
which  It allows for many, many, many, many
more
addresses, but it's currently
very little used. At the IPv6 level, there are
some minor issues...
how to put it... there's no
conflict between IPv4 and
IPv6 if they're incompatible.
We know how to create
less cobbled-together gateways between the two, but they
are two relatively
incompatible networks. It just so happens that
currently, most
equipment can handle both
protocols, but we only use version
V4. What problem will this pose in
geopolitical terms? It's very
simple: there aren't enough IPv4 addresses,
there are many IPv6 addresses. This
means that more and more
internet access will be
provided on IPv6 addresses, while
server access will remain on
IPv4 addresses. This means we will have created an
asymmetric internet, an internet where
servers are not connected
in the same way as clients, and that's
a problem. It's all the more of a
problem because... a little more  50% of
IP addresses are
American. The United States consumes 50
% of the resource while representing only 5%
of the population. This is also a
problem, and it will tend to
damage the internet by making it
much closer to a Mitel model where
clients and servers are not on
equal footing. Furthermore, it will
accentuate the concentration of servers in the United States and become
structural, no longer just a random occurrence
of economic life, but rather
encoded into the
system's structure. This is a huge, huge,
huge problem. So, countries
that are asking themselves a lot of questions about
internet governance should
think about
this. It's not very complicated to address
technically; basically, it's about encouraging
operators to switch
everything to IPv6—not just
subscriptions, but also servers,
websites, access, and so on.
In fact, for me, it's
a tandem approach, similar to what
the European Parliament did on net
neutrality.  By forcing
operators to remain on an
open system and an open network, if what was
voted on in the European Parliament eventually
becomes a truly
applicable regulation, we will have a very
interesting first step. The second step is to
have a very strong incentive to
switch everything to V6, not just
subscriptions but everything, and to do it quickly
to avoid the shortage that is
developing on V4 and the kind of
unhealthy and
nauseating economy where IP addresses are bought and sold,
which makes no
sense. So there is an
extremely strong geopolitical issue at stake for the network, and you can be certain
that the last ones to move to get
everything on V6 will be the Americans
because it makes them lose the
control they have over the network.
Okay, we
see the problem in other
areas; this is one element. When we
talk about Internet governance, we don't need to
rack our brains to figure out who
will join Dean's side, except perhaps the
Department of Commerce.  Is it
the UN? Is it
UNESCO? Is it some
international agency in Geneva?
Who cares? That's not the point. That doesn't
matter. We can
look at it; it's keeping the diplomats busy. We
need to let a nobody sort it out. But the
real issue isn't there. The real issue is
technical, and the real
technical issue is how to
force the network to stay open. I'll give you some
coocalan. You started your
sentence by saying it's like trying to
govern a puddle. At best, we can contain it. That's it. At
best, we can
try to
contain it, especially not the competition. Do
you think the military programming law
and all the legislative arsenal
put in place are a way of trying to
contain the FAD (Front for the Defense of the Sovereign Forces), without using the
term "following" by Gustave Le Bon, "The Psychology
of Crowds"? Do you think the
psychology of crowds has brought a
puddle of water?  Isn't the
legislative arsenal a way of
containing the people and their
access to knowledge?
Article 13, Article 1 V of the
military programming law, is in fact a way
of enabling—well, it's a tool
the executive branch uses to
monitor and control the population.
It's very clearly social control. It's
not for hunting down terrorists, it's not
for hunting down evil pedophiles/Nazis; that's done
in the
penal code. When we do it in the
military programming law for the
intelligence services, that is,
for the secret agents, and when we basically give them
full powers in terms of
surveillance, it's because we're
trying to create a small
French NSA. We're doing it in a Pi-
Niclé way because we don't have the budgets, but
the goal is clearly for a form of
police force—a secret, high-powered job
done by elites—to constantly monitor
what the population is doing,
with a certain number of
powers within the rule of law.  Does it
worry you when you see
that Europe is sliding
into much more
unstable governments, that there are movements like the
Occupy Wall Street movement, movements that
demand answers? Does it
worry you that this type of
legitimate violence, wielded by a state, still manages to get away with it,
especially the
way it was carried out? Of course it worries me,
obviously it
worries me, but I don't see an
immediate correlation between the two. That
politicians, who are
essentially the guardians
of the old world today, would like nothing to
change because they want to stay at the
top of the pyramid, and it's not even necessarily
conscious, but so they
make laws in that direction. So they
make laws aimed at controlling the
population because they sense that the
population is restless. They make laws
aimed at preventing the internet from overflowing
because they don't understand anything about the
internet. It's not with
totalitarian aims. I'm not sure it's entirely
linked to the rise of
totalitarianism. The rise of
totalitarianism in Europe is...  It's blatant,
and it's rather linked to
macroeconomic issues.
You find the same rise of
totalitarianism in 1930s Europe
for similar reasons:
the distribution of wealth produced, the
economic structures.
To put it simply, when
finance collapses, five years
later fascism rises in Europe. That's how it is.
Finance collapsed
in 2008, fascism is
rising in Europe. That's how it is, and
it's for the same reasons as in 1929. There wasn't a
profound change. Back then, it
took very
particular forms in Europe,
but it's the same problem. It's the
same
capitalist delusion where we see
capital income, and therefore the price of capital,
increase, labor income decrease, and
the distribution of wealth become distorted.
So basically, you look at what the
top 10% own.  The wealth of a
country versus what the poorest 50% own,
and the more wealth
increases, the more tension there is in
society. This tension is
always resolved by the fact that the powerful,
who are quite close to the rich,
want
things to remain stable, for the
world not to change, and therefore do everything
to prevent the world from changing and
creating tension. Social tension
becomes
political tension. This is how we drift
towards totalitarian systems, and we
see several building blocks right now.
Yes, you have the CSA (French Broadcasting Authority), which is a building block;
yes, you have the military programming law,
which is a building block; you have the whole
system of financial regulation by
constraint. What we are doing with such blatant disregard is stupid.
All of this is connected.
The fact that the fascists are going to
come to power is not a
consequence of the internet, and it is not a
consequence of the military programming law.
Both are
consequences of the same phenomenon: a
society that is going
wrong.
Thank you. All of this rests on the principle of
trust in systems and the
principle of justice.  Reciprocity, but it's
obvious
that we can have very
significant shifts, meaning there's no longer
reciprocity, but we've gone beyond the
listening stage. That's the problem; it's no
longer the service that will tap
into the line and listen to what's
happening, or even intercept
what's happening. The Pino Simplify system
is finished. There you go, we're now in the
data collection phase. If there's any doubt, there's
no doubt. That is to say, every time a
trader, every time a
director, every time they met and made
decisions contrary to
the basic ethics of a firm, they were
dismissed.